Dalvin cook here on the Richard show how
you doing Dalvin I'm doing good
yes you are doing good you're doing
better than that you were doing way
better than that how are you feeling
right now
walk me through what's going on between
your temples I'm pretty good and I'm not
the game you know pretty much getting
back in the routine and looking at my
body right
okay ready for Green Bay but in terms of
that in terms of that I mean just the
guy who went through rehab the guy who
rehabbed an injured knee the guy who
went through all the heartache and pain
to get back what would that guy think
right now yeah it's gonna journey no
just no diving back just going through
something that I've never been to so no
everything was new to me but you know
taking a step back from the game no
really just got my mind know the focus
on the game and another thing only come
around once so you got to cherish it
yeah you know I just bend the stuff in
the ground and just just working it's
definitely been a journey came back to
now walk me through that when you say
that removing yourself from the game was
beneficial or at least it's given you
fresh perspective why is that yeah it
makes you cherish the guys in a locker
room
make you just know going on the field
and being out there in the meeting rooms
and on practice
no grind on those days on account you
know with the guys know you cherish
those moments and know every day you
know I want to go out there and get
better something I want to get better
every day so I can help my team win no
that's what it really opened my eyes up
to well so much has been talked about
you know rehabbing from injuries
obviously Andrew Luck's retirement
focused in a lot of fans in on that
aspect of this game that's that's not
played out in public how lonely is that
process Delvin cook they're definitely
frustrated in the stream just being
Noli player and planted game for so long
and there's something that we love to do
not be inevitable go out there and
compete with your teammates and when
football games is in our nature and so
we want to be out there and it's just
frustrating just not being out there and
just going through the whole recovery
process what you want to be focusing on
football again better to cry
know that that just set you back in it
just make you frustrating so it
definitely commenced with tomorrow a lot
well now your mind is clearly right do
you feel like this is as good as you've
ever been
Delvin right now I'm coming into comment
coming into it when I got Jack I was I
was pretty much Roland I told my idea
about week four and you know I just feel
like I'm just back to them you know
being the player that I am and just just
understanding the game more and you're
studying more and just know having a
would just want to win or every play
that touch the ball or don't touch the
ball I just wanna know win football game
what did it mean for you to do what you
did on the same field as a guy who you
not only succeeded at Miami Central High
School but also Florida State and
Devonta Freeman gallon and it meant a
lot because you know he really pretty
much know set the blueprint that it can
be done know coming from you know just a
kid for Miami he you know he said to
tone know being on the field with a Miss
definitely was a experience that I know
forget well we're showing your Jersey
exchange with him after the game where
where have you placed this jersey where
where is your Freeman Jersey going I'm
gonna I'm gonna drop it off the day so I
get it framed up and I'm gonna put it up
on a wall just you know put it in a
special place whose other Jersey do you
have oh I got caddy
I got Mark angle I did a stain um okay
latavius Murray those guys okay
would you like to do in exchange here I
can give you this shirt that I have on
right now it's a very good button-down
shirt it is a shade of lavender so it
would kind of match the Vikings coloring
away Dalman would you want to do that
well we could do that I mean I don't
know if it's as valuable as is what you
have it's it's kind of an older shirt
it's heading towards retirement I think
my wife looks at the collar and she
would like it retired but it does look
good on camera Dalvin would you like to
do that can we do that we could do that
okay by the way I know I'm gonna hold
you to it would you you have to frame
this though
no you have to frame it and but it is a
Rich Eisen show worn shirt Dalman I got
you good all right don't just say that I
got to see it up on the wall cuz I would
definitely stop I could put the Dalvin
cook one up on the wall here
easy that's simple yeah okay what is the
this the t-shirt you gave your offensive
lineman chef cook what is that all about
Delmon yeah something that that I pretty
much know dancing cause I got here I got
it I got the NFL you know we've been
we've been trying to cook this thing up
and it is pretty much just basically you
know off my off my last name and pretty
much my brand and what I go by sitting
on the Shelf cooking it up so what are
the ingredients
um it's a little bit of blocking it with
God and be doing the rest okay very good
now um how is Gary Kubiak changed things
around there darlin oh you got him in
close too fast you coach Dennis now all
those guys know great officer market no
people and smart people and you know
they came in and set the tone right away
no we want to be a physical smart group
and that's been our mindset and I
mentality since we came at OTAs and
minicamp you know so this thing has been
again being installed in us and we've
been rapping and meeting and just know
just coming up with what I didn't he
wanted to be that's been identity since
those those people stuff in the building
okay and what are your personal goals
you write them down I know am it used to
do that what do you do just know set up
some bullet points just for you know
what I want to attack you know what I
what I want to be good at it and I want
to start this season infinity seas and
you know there's really no like no hope
it's not like that it is nobody's just
down on top of my game so give me some
of the bullet points because the it
certainly worked in week number one I
mean you were dynamite no question about
that Dhawan that was one of those no
start to see the fast house at all okay
all right let's check that box we check
that box
what's the next box
I'm just pretty much mom nice my body
goes it really just stays there on my
body though she's my stylist and the
right routine like no matter what type
of game I have it was a good or Fagin
just make sure you stick to your routine
and get your body going for the next
week
and what did you see it what are you
anything and then what's after that and
just pretty much knows this make sure
there's no it could be a log in the
middle of the sea just it's pretty much
play so you just stay motivated keep the
mana to it and when we eight week now
know that those grinding out games know
what you nicked up or no kind of sword
just let that be the games you gotta
know push yourself in alright be good
game before I let you go down and cook
you go to Lambeau Field coming up this
is a huge one I mean this is a big one
both of you both your teams are want to
know and would would take the lead at
two and Oh early on in this division I'm
wondering what this game means for you
where you are coming off of that game
into a rivalry contest Dalvin cook big
division game we gotta go and you know
pretty much set the tone for the
division and I'll be trying to go win a
football game end of the day so you know
the same month every week go in and try
to good no dub okay and one last thing
is Florida State and Mike Zimmer is your
coach do you know that Deion Sanders and
coach Zimmer are really tight Dalvin are
you aware of that yeah okay
as prime reached out on your behalf to
coach Zimmer at any point in time are
you aware of that
okay all right I just want to make sure
that prime is a guy I know you prom is
out there on your behalf Delvin that is
for sure okay
hey Dalvin you take care of yourself
okay I appreciate you calling it today
Congrats on that big that big start that
was awesome I appreciate you got it
that's a Dobbin cook for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app